describing is great and accurate other
monetization options from the up in
Africa I've been merchandising less than
huge and will usually do little
commercials at the end of our video so
my tank buy a t-shirt are showing them
what the merchandise is directly related
to to the series youtube partnership is
being open up to everyone right now so
if you're making videos and if you have
a video that like games views rapidly
YouTube will contact you and how are
doing say hey we got us your videos
going really well want to make some
money and so you'd say yes so ultimately
you know you'd be able to actually make
our entire channel a partner with
YouTube so that's that's that's a huge
minute and I've been a partner for about
two to three years and joining with full
screen has helped me to get a higher
sleep in because the bees are so low I'm
sorry the rates are so low so there's
that and there's
there's just different you know any of
that when do we do Brandon and Brandon
genetic entertainment and product
placement it is huge for us as well and
our actual website directing people to
your actual website is very helpful if
you want to if you want to have brands
go there and say hey do you want to put
a banner on my website because I have
traffic here so it's really important to
check google analytics good stats crowd
boost or things like that really help
you to get ahold of what your
demographic is because that's what
advertisers care about the most may have
a really strong hold on watches our show
seven questions how would you compare
just the standard kind of like when
google's like hey Justin use
Kirko like someone from a channel
hey we've got this chin
I think it's helpful to be a partner you
guys can correctly but it's helpful to
be a partner with YouTube first just so
you can sort of build a file and get get
an audience and chances are network
isn't really gonna approach you unless
you have you know unless you're already
a partner and they see that you are
getting being so if you have the
opportunity to become a partner take it
he really won't be losing
Oh
yes
or
Wow
um so usually you can help pride of your
partner so they have something at the
bottom somewhere it says contact us and
our YouTube partners are really really
boring before though if you have a video
they're gaining popularity and it's not
even like thousands of you spot where it
could be just like oh I got to 340
really bad I'll contact you about a
specific video and ask a few of the
monetize that specific video if you want
to have a channel partnership and you
can really about it and they'll contact
you give you details yeah you can look
into it
how many of you applied for the partner
program were denied and then I think
what is the three months you can apply
later and what did it take for your
friend of the accept a because there's
no is there like a magic number as to
what would make you a partner I'll be
able to find that number
no we never applied because we and over
whatever that number one
so when actually when PBS contact us
partner through their network
more mature
it strikes to that of a friend like I
was a partner and I didn't even know
about the partnership program until
YouTube contacted me but then I had
that's all I'm exclusive and special but
then I had another friend like it just
started a web series and they had like
300 views and to you know contact info
like okay clearly this is not that hard
so it doesn't really doesn't really
matter I think it's just about they want
to know that you're going to
consistently producing videos like
that's important today because of your
kind of producing at a constant rate may
have want opportunities to make money
off fresh content so i would get
discouraged you ask it clearly the
apartment yeah yeah i mean actually
she's right like i have a friend who
peak post on facebook sometime last year
like he just became a youtube partner
and he doesn't post up consistently he
had like 200 hits
confusing and they've also sort of like
redefined what partner means now and so
now it has open to everybody so it used
to be like you would get rejected but
now it's it's basically you apply in any
area that's on your stuff like this is
certain pages in our
one of the one of the benefits of being
a partner is you can get customizable
thumbnails so you can change the way of
the preview that people see because you
know usually if you what a video to
YouTube it just kind of like Nick's
three random shots either but if you a
partner there used to be when you join
the partnership that you would get that
customizable teacher of customizable
thumbnails but I think of the new sort
of system anybody can make him a partner
but that feature
how many people do you all know who make
a living doing YouTube videos and they
pay the rent they and support them
something several people I'm quite a bit
too
I know her I mean like you know yeah the
bucs people I we just kind of know you
need along the way and you know not us
but so are our background is sort of in
the independent build community and so
most people you know very few people who
make stuff on YouTube anybody who's
making a living on YouTube that we know
now is we only that past couple months
through making these videos
people the great thing about YouTube is
the community is really tight all the
people with great stuff for friends get
along help each other out collaborations
and stuff and there's advances VidCon
just to mention for YouTube
get togethers and stuff so
and on that farm on how often do you do
collaborations with other youtubers how
many would you say bike how many videos
with you tickle t-post a month and of
those how many would be a collaboration
right now I hadn't posted on the web
series in the past I've done a lot
vibrations
willing to tell me just asking
VidCon every summer
there
to VidCon VI d ceylon um I i find that
everyone likes to collaborate and they
love to do it just because it's in the
spirit of creating but also because the
fans go crazy if they're watching the
favorite channel they're like oh my god
that's in this drink which our guy or
any kind of crossover anyone who's in
the YouTube world loves giving that to
their fans and getting them getting
excited about you know how it all
interacts um I forgot the original
question oh um I know I know quite a few
people actually I've been working in the
web space for a while so most everyone I
know makes a living doing web content
one way or the other whether tis are
getting higher than other people shows
or whether it's through actual YouTube
ads and everything but a lot of them do
and we're not talking like well some of
them are in mansions but most of them
are not I mean they're still making
teacher salary which is a nice salary to
be doing what you love but it's still
your existing on it you know and its
really nice also the community that you
build you have your own fans and they're
yours and that's different than if
you're working on something else
and I think as filmmakers it's it's
always to grow your channel it helps to
work with these bigger youtubers so if
you're a filmmaker and you have a
project you cast somebody from youtube
and then help you solve out
just real quickly I think Stephen or
Patrick one of you said that most of
people you know on YouTube aren't
filmmakers did you say that or maybe I'm
hallucinates don't know okay all right
well it does seem like there is sort of
a divided and is it because the age
demographic and we went to VidCon I
can't tell you how yeah you're like no
I'm not someone's mom I actually but I
mean do you think that disconnect lies
because I think there is sort of this
this divide and the YouTube community
does seem very collaborative so where do
you think that divide lives okay the
divide between the fact that a lot of
independent filmmakers aren't on youtube
as much as just people that just make a
web series and different things like
that i think and i used to definitely
suffer from this too is I think most
filmmakers think they're too good for
you too I mean I went to film school and
my classmates would not put anything on
YouTube you know that's like maybe I'll
put it on vimeo
password protected but so i think i
think it's sort of like the you know
sort of stigma oh it's just like cat
videos and stuff like that so it's hard
for people you know I put a lot of work
into this project I don't want to just
put it on youtube I want to go the film
festival route and so I think a lot of
people i know or think that YouTube
isn't right for them I possibly don't
understand the opportunities to to get
your work scene and and how important
you know it is to to have as many you
know people see it work as it used to be
just cat videos in first birthdays but
it's evolved more than just a place
where you post videos it's more of a
forum it's more of an expression and I
remember watching the movie the artist
and with him learning the talkies I felt
like that's our industry right now with
moving online that's the talkies of our
generation is moving online because that
is going to be the future of it and I
think a lot of people haven't realized
that but I also think the huge divide is
the fact that the good news and the bad
news the good news is not with digital
cameras anyone can make me the bad news
no with digital cameras anyone can make
a movie so a lot of people who have
never been to film school who don't know
what crossing line is or anything like
that they're still making movies and
flooding the area that being said the
quality Rises and people find it and but
that's why there's such a divided of
people who really good really know what
they're talking about I had a meeting
once with um I don't think the websites
still around but it's a comedy website
and I was pitching to them a show and I
shot a trailer our first episode to show
it to them and they were like we love it
we love it um I was wondering if you
could make it look worse and I was like
what and they said could you make it
worse could you do worse camera work and
maybe not light it so well and could
your actors maybe not be so great
they sit because that's what goes viral
is these really bad videos that are
poorly made and I think they missed the
point I think they bought videos of a
viral or just true human expressions and
moments that people enjoy or light to
mock that a lot of really well produced
projects don't necessarily capture so I
think they were missing the mark but I
think that's why so many people think
that I'm YouTube you have to have bad
quality work and you don't even an
excellent quality work and still get
recognized and be popular and go viral
and keep that phrase
so this is our sort of standard film
courage question oh and all go ahead
I think for one thing I've understanding
that is that short form is what really
really helps the web people have really
really short attention spans you're not
going to make a 30-minute series for the
web if you don't have a following
immediately and that means that I think
that you need to like it's really
interactive there's a huge interactive
elevate for web as well so if you're not
if you're not working
you're not working on sort of repeating
the audience then you can't you won't
not necessarily succeed on the web so I
think that it's just a completely in
just two different mediums you can't
really measure
so I can't even hear you
we're transitioning
I think I'm speaking more like building
a following the yes I completely agree i
think they're they're definitely using
right now yep like school it'll take
nachos like starting out i think that is
very important to start for the way
i'm at well now that i have to make i
realized i'll probably just keep
repeating what you just said it's TV and
the weather this is different as TV in a
movie the Lea structure the story what
happens to the characters the journeys
they go on is completely different it'd
be the same thing as different as like a
short film versus a future versus a TV
show and in the best way it's kind of an
intangible but it's kind of not at the
same time I think all of us all of us
are still trying to figure out what the
formulas that work specifically on the
web but i think it's simpler plot points
but it doesn't mean that it means less
but if you watch ones that are doing
really well you can see what it is and
it's not that it's a one episode of a
30-minute TV show split into parts it's
each episode as a beginning middle and
end and then there's journey for your
your actors and yeah i should have just
not taken mike but don't fight i helped
a little cuz she just wanted to know if
there's anything that we could pinpoint
that would make a successful web series
that seem to do better on the web then
something else for me my experience has
been comedy i'm a lot of people watching
web series usually watching it at work
and they don't usually want to tune in
to watch a horror movie or a drama so I
find comedy is better I find that if you
start this is what she was saying as
well but the first couple of episodes
are stewed for sure because people it's
funny time it's like it's like time
warps when you're online and if you were
to watch it on tivo or net let you bet
go half hour I can watch on a flower
show you're watching it online you're
like five minute no way I'm going to
watch five I don't even know what this
is but if it if you start off shore like
under four minutes or so for your first
couple episodes and once you gain your
audience then they'll go with you on
that journey for you know a legend of
neil which is
it was serious out there they turned up
with really short episodes by the time I
got into our last season I think they
were like 15 minute long as I so it's
bed time they got done and they could
then because they had the audience but
starting off short Island I think comedy
and I think it needs to be something
that resonates with people it needs to
be an interesting experience like David
human is a great web series that I used
to watch and that's great because it's
about the dating scene but some kind of
an unusual situation just literally
she's dating aliens and your show is
hilarious if you haven't watched it it's
so great because it just resonates in so
many different levels so it's something
that means something to you because it
means something new finding something
other people and something that
entertains you the same reason that's
what I would say
I think they're I think there is an
audience for the for longer web series
but like she said its people that
already have an audience and they are
like make something longer make
something bigger so you have to work
towards them like that there's this guy
Freddy walked out
video game high school and he gets
millions of hits on every every episode
and he put it on his own website it's
made
website where he doesn't have to share
the monetization as he already has
values
so leave the club
I'm coming
for any one individual
just technically
amounts to that
situation
did everybody hear
we actually used to do that did
everybody hit we actually that with the
guys I used agrees with I would put on
my channel that we put it on there and I
still find that just for monetization
was kind of annoying and that YouTube
didn't like it because it was just a
duplicate video as well so yeah I don't
really find it a good idea especially if
you aren't going to be approached by
brass or later they want to know that
all your content in one place and you
can a great views of the one area so it
is kind of shooting yourself in the foot
if it's like oh my how about to beat
here in this I am twenty thousand years
this is kind of you're taking money away
what's take the opportunity to
out there so while we're talking about
you know water down content whatever
thinking you guys touch on having
multiple YouTube channels or something
we see with a lot of people that are
larger on YouTube is they do have
multiple channels can can you guys on
share some thoughts on that in terms of
wouldn't wouldn't you want to just have
one channel were the reasons why you
would have more than one channel with
you guys touch on that yeah personally
well I know that a lot of viewers if
they're turning it to your channel for
one type of video or 11 or two shows if
you start making something like for
example if I'm making comedy videos and
then I'm like whoa I want to do a
cooking video then they're gonna be like
what I'm subscribe to you for this
cooking it like okay good it's all going
I'm so that's very important just a pure
if you're gonna have a specific genre
keep it
the channel consistent with food is on
so i have 1 minute that / that the hard
way to I haven't I built this huge
audience with awkward black girl which
is like specific type types of people
and then I wanted to make something
completely ignorant and they hated it so
that's hard so I'm a separate channel
when I do behind the scenes things or if
I'm going to do something for me then
you know father I think that
well we have one channel but but I mean
we do think about like you know but
who's just trying to build your brand
and get your audience and like when you
decide to actually
like if you do want to make it a channel
it's because there's a reason to do it
not because like
Oh keep it
we do want to ask somebody about this
and said you know like we're putting so
much work into building that one channel
they're so small still it's like it just
being kind of losing focus if you're
trying to build the second channel on
top of sleep sleeping is going to do but
when you say you're putting a lot of
work into your channel I give me an idea
of what your days like what is this work
that you're referring to so
we spend a lot of time writing shooting
and editing so we put out a video every
week roughly two two and a half minutes
long what we do is we kind of cluster
our shoots together so we can shoot one
week we'll maybe shoot like four
episodes which will be enough for a
month so it kind of goes in little
spritz will be like in a writing mode or
just writing stuff and you know we'll
write for a couple hours each day during
that time you know we put I estimated
it's about 20 hours of video work that
goes into making one for us maybe four
hours writing a couple hours showing and
the rest is editing and you know we're
keeping up we just have to just built a
website so I'm going to start a website
with a blog we do all the social media
stuff
facebooktwitter we somehow got feature
my are tumbling got featured by tumblr
in their film section so we have all
these people who are following us on
tumblr but we don't really know what to
do because they put a video and they
don't like it for watching but if we put
a video or if we put a picture of like
harrison.part it's a happy birthday
it'll get a lot of likes so a lot of a
lot of stuff building making t-shirts
right now so a lot of focus on the on
the making of the actual videos setting
those up writing them setting up
interviews brainstorming new ideas all
that outreach you knowing you guys and
you'll share this video things like that
Ryan I'm hoping you can touch touch on
sort of the the evolution of your
youtube career making you can you sort
of compare and contrast your early days
on YouTube the amount of work that you
put in sort of working on the videos as
opposed to the work that you put into
promoting the video and how that's
changed over time no because I sort of
imagine that when you first started
maybe you put less time into the videos
and more time to promote it to get
people to see it and then as time is
going on you put more and more time into
the video unless unless time to promote
it can you just talk a little bit about
about that yeah when I first started the
quality on YouTube no matter what you
did was going to be crappy and they
didn't have SLR cameras they didn't
really matter to make the high-quality
thing was just about keeping your
audience engaged
putting a video out once a week or
whatever you can and now that the now
with these new SLR cameras everybody got
some and everybody's making stuff and
you have to compete with the other other
youtubers so you quality has to rise or
other people the fans are going to watch
but it's also i mean i always i wish
that we can go back and like redo the
whole videos because you're like you'd
be 100 megabytes big and it some crap
let's do it and i do you work harder at
all when you get back though um I think
it's pretty much the same or it's all
relative I don't know I think it still
requires the same amount of work